[Music]
you know his name you know his face now
you'll know the answer to the question
why has been to Cumberbatch in
everything these days
Sherlock the world's most famous
detective returns to the screen for like
the 200th time but this show is more
than a rehash of public domain stories
from the 1890s
now they blog I've written a blog on the
varying tensile strengths of different
natural fibres for their title look
about us next time they reboot Sherlock
what's it gonna be a bind star isn't he
what was that
Oh r.i.p vine meet Sherlock Holmes
consulting detective
obsessive-compulsive and
high-functioning sociopath I'm a
high-functioning sociopath high
functioning sociopath which is all just
Sherlock speak for he's a ginormous dick
to everyone she could be trying to yes
thank you for your input thrill as he
solves London's toughest crimes armed
only with the ability to make helpful
words float in thin air
and the power of knowing whatever the
script needs him to know how do you know
he showed you because I do while
Sherlock is a man who's all brain and no
heart he's joined by dr. Watson a man
who's all heart and no brain watch him
endure endless abuse and still stick by
his roommates side because someone has
to give a good reaction face
[Music]
a few of those are from the office pet
you didn't even notice get ready for a
mystery series that's actually a
superhero show in disguise
complete with a super-powered main
character a trusty sidekick a city to
protect and great bad guys like Moriarty
honey you should see me in a crown that
dream sequence with Moriarty in it and
the video implying Moriarty is back for
season 4 but otherwise the criminal
turns out to be whatever actor is a
small pointless speaking role Law &
Order rules guys they're universal so
pour yourself a cup of tea continue your
morning tea tea company and be lovely
toss on your favorite scarf no
difficulty bride problem and enjoy a
witty smart clever show that's
obnoxiously aware of how witty smart and
clever it is some clever clever yes as
it keeps you on the edge of your seat
trying to solve the latest puzzles and
cliffhangers then spits in your face for
even bothering to try do you want to see
believe if you have enough stupid
theories it's gonna change what really
happened and makes you care about
Benedict Cumberbatch's portrayal of the
character then implies you're a loser
for loving him you'd be a fan of
Sherlock Holmes will excuse me for
loving your beautiful shark face I'm
sure elementary on CBS would appreciate
my attention what are you cooking in
those pots oh this is not black lakrisha
nose belts splash of feline urine never
mind
starring i'll tumbler for you the
original Cumberbatch textaid I prefer to
text he's texting me now he text me the
details of text yeah I'll text you
Moriarty licking stuff
[Music]
Sherlock sniffing things obviously yes
obviously yes obviously she obviously
some sort of code obviously obviously
obviously
Sherlock having no friends he doesn't
have friends how many friends do you
imagine he has I don't have friends I
don't have it's a friend an enemy Oh
which one the way British people say
aluminium to claims were the one about
the aluminium crutch that what about
that yes Sherlock being unimpressed Suns
a bit doubts she's boring boring boring
dull dull boring predictable Watson's
adorable little ride I've been calling
you
[Music]
Sherlock's reverse smile wasn't it and
the roast of Sherlock's had likely
coming soon to screen jockeys plus I
like your funny hat detect you for one
of the city hat the clever detective in
the funny hat
Downton crabby come on be honest
Sherlock you figure things out the same
way everyone else does these days okay I
learnt it on YouTube ah I knew it hey
Sherlock fans do you want some more
sweet exclusive Benedict Cumberbatch
footage well then you're in luck check
out honest interviews our first series
from the team behind honest trailers
where we sit down with your favorite
stars and ask them to do silly stuff
Ralph Wiggum he's a favorite smells like
food but that's not all we've got big
news you can watch the first episode
right now in our brand new channel
screen junkies news that's right we just
launched a second youtube channel
devoted to live breaking movie and TV
news coverage featuring all your
favorite screen junkies and more so you
can check out the first honest interview
and subscribe to get daily live news
coverage screen junkies news the only
place on the internet for entertainment
news coverage except for all those other
places but hey did we mention is free
you guys like free i'm david pumpkins
any questions you have failed this kitty
never Chewbacca
I remember Chewbacca suck my nuts I am a
400-foot tall platypus bear with pink
horns and silver wings do you like
waffles